I have to ask before we uh Land This
Plane because you mentioned um working
with people like Geraldo and Mitch
Hedberg was the one for me that the best
the best like he's Sinbad's the guy I
saw on TV first yeah and was just like
first comic I ever saw on television and
I was like oh that looks fun and he's
just funky and having a good time and
he's clean which I've always been just
just it just kind of what was naturally
funny to me me too but I like all comedy
but uh too I'm the same way it it was
but edberg was the comedian I think I
just the first one I just listened to on
repeat over and over and over again and
you got did you get to work with him oh
yeah I have the best Mitch stories um so
to your point Bill Cosby was the first
one I ever saw cuz my parents I grew up
in a very strict Southern Baptist home
so uh I did not have you know Lenny
Bruce and George Carlin records on in
the background like we watched Bill
Cosby himself which ironically is even
creepier or something um you know yeah
some Jeff Foxworthy tapes maybe in the
car on the way to vacation and then uh
and then I would I would watch evening
at The Improv that was my like that was
the show that I would watch standup
comedy on and Wendy lean Larry Miller
and step Wright was like my guy I love
word play I love puns Steven Wright of
all the ones I'd seen was like this is
my
dude so fast forward I'm doing
standup um I'm doing it this is before I
was full-time um and someone at my job
brings me a Time magazine that had just
done a special piece on
Montreal and uh they had gone over
Seinfeld had just gone off the air and
so the piece was about the new faces at
Montreal of seeing are any of these
people the next Seinfeld and it was like
Horatio Sans there was like a bunch of
names that you would even recognize
today and the and the main star of the
article was Mitch Hedberg and someone
was just like here this is about standup
you'd like it you know and so I was like
reading about it and then uh the guy
from go bananas called me into his
office and he says I'm thinking about
bringing this guy to the club and he
plays this clip of Mitch on Louie
Anderson's um like comic strip live or
or whatever show that was and uh and I
was like this is like the modern day
Mach or the modern day Steven Wright
yeah like this is my guy I was like
you've got to let me MC for this dude
when he comes here and so he did and so
um so he let me open for Mitch and then
um I was booked the next week to MC in
Dayton uh which is like 45 minutes from
Cincinnati and that head liner cancelled
the week before so the Dayton club
called go bananas and said would Mitch
like to just stick around this part of
the country and work our club next week
and he did so I worked with Mitch two
weeks back to back as his opener and um
and he was so fun to hang out with he
wanted to go to movies we went bowling
and uh I was like as soon as I got off
work I would drive up and then we would
go do something fun before the show and
so um it went so well this was probably
like April or May of
99 and then that um December for New
Year's Eve they booked him again to
headline New Year's Eve 99
2000 and I was an IT guy so everybody
was worried about y 2K so I was they
gave me the week at the club but I had
to leave at midnight to go back to work
just in case like the world's computer
shut down or whatever wow and so before
I left Mitch
said do you want to come open for me in
North Dakota in February in Grand Forks
North Dakota at this old club called the
westward hoe and uh he was like I'm
doing a special show on Valentine's Day
and I was like absolutely so I took
vacation and I drove to North
Dakota and uh I did this show Mitch had
Bergen friends and it was awesome and he
on that trip uh so that would have been
yeah February of 2000 he's like quit
your job and I'm like I can't quit my
job and he's like quit your job call
your BOS this is like Saturday night at
like 3:00 in the morning call him right
now tell them you're not coming in I was
like R I can't there's no chance that I
can quit my job right now he's like you
need to quit for your job and I was like
I can't do it and so I went back home
and then we we' kind of stayed in touch
I would randomly take vacation days to
go work with him on the road if he would
call and so when I decided to quit my
job uh in early of1 I said hey I called
my parents and I called Mitch and he was
a second person I called and I said I'm
quitting my job to do comedy full- time
and he said what's your last day and he
and I said Friday the 13th of July 2001
and he goes so what does that mean the
next week's your full-time the you know
your first week is a full-time comic and
I said yeah and he said what club have
you always wanted to work that you've
never worked and I was like well there's
a million of them but at the time the
laugh stop in Houston was the club
that's where like Dane Cook and Louis CK
like everybody was recording their
albums in there it was just kind of
known as like one of the best Bill Hicks
come up there to I think so yeah yes he
did for sure yeah
um and so I was like what about the
laugh stop in Houston and he hung up and
he called me back and he said your first
week is a full-time comic you're
featuring for me at the laugh stop in
Houston and I was like what so I went
down there and then almost once a month
he would say where are you trying to get
into that you can't get into and I would
say
Atlanta and so he was the reason that I
got into Atlanta to the punchline for
the first time was because he brought me
here with
him and at the old Club in The Green
Room everybody signed the wall and that
first time I was here and I just I think
I put the punchline this is why you
become a comedian and I wrote the first
time that I was there like the the day
uh the month and the year and then every
time I came back I would just add the
month and the year to it and so when
they closed the old Club down I took a
picture next to it and there was like 17
wow dates or something of times that
that I had been here but the first time
was with Mitch and uh and I'll give you
two quick stories I know we're over time
there's no I mean I know your I know
your wife had called you but she's
fine we talking about Mitch D yo y let
let him fly man this uh so one time when
we were here um like when you work with
Mitch a lot you start to talk like him
and you start to write like him like
it's just like it's just weird like it
you can't help it you know you just you
get used to his Cadence cuz I would
never miss a set like I just he's the
best of all time so were his sets always
different or was he pretty scripted he
was all over the place you know he had
he had his book I mean it was so
important to him because his jokes were
so short they were easy for people to
memorize so I mean you can imagine what
it would be like today in the social
media world with Hedberg like he would
be a billionaire just on viral cuz just
boom bo 30 second Clips you of full
jokes um not to derail your story no no
but like it it was sometimes it would be
to his detriment that he wanted to have
new stuff so bad cuz people would yell
out jokes that they want to hear and
he'd be like why do you want to hear
that you know you already know the
answer to it I'm going to write new
stuff you know and then he would like he
would he would sort of um not depression
per se but like he would become obsessed
with how much the crowd was enjoying the
show and would and would be very hard on
himself you know um and it was like
everybody else is like this guy's a
genius like just do whatever you want
and people would be on board with it but
he was always so worried about what
people thought and so I was starting to
write jokes that like just didn't make
sense for my ACT but they were were kind
of written in Mitch's voice and I I went
to him and I was like would you want to
would you want any of these you know I
think they're funny but like they just
don't make sense if I do them and he's
like they are funny but you need to do
them and I'm like they don't make sense
if I do them and I go they're like your
voice he's like there you need to do
them and I'm like well just never mind
then so we're we're at the old punch
line and uh he's on stage and he goes uh
it's like halfway through his set he
goes hey John you you still in here and
I was at the back and I was like yeah
I'm here he's like y'all remember Josh
right well he wrote jokes that are funny
but he don't want to do them he wants me
to do them I'm gonna make him come up
here and do
them he's like you want to hear the J
jokes Josh wrote for me everybody was
like you know so I went on stage and I
was like why wrote These jokes as Mitch
so if I'm going to do him I need to do
him as Mitch so I like close my eyes and
I get you know right up on the
microphone fun but oh yeah and everybody
start giggling you know and then I would
do these like four or five like little
punny you know Mitch style jokes and
they did really well and then you know
the few times after that that I would
worked with him that's what he would do
he'd bring me up and have me do the
jokes I wrote for him so one you know
like he was so good to me and and to so
many people but I never felt
like there was anything I could do for
him certainly not financially or within
the business like there's no way I could
repay him you know so I was walking
around the I think was like the
Perimeter mall or something one day
killing time and I Came Upon A a
Build-A-Bear shop and they had Koalas in
there and so uh I was like can you like
record your voice and and like stick it
in here and they're like yeah and so I
did all Mitch's koala jokes as Mitch you
know and uh and like if you press the
Paw you know it' be like hey Mitch Feed
me a leaf you know and so uh so I gave
it to him that night at at the punchline
and I was just like this is just
something dumb just to say you know
thank you for all that you've done for
me and uh and then when his next album
came out Mitch all together there's a
liner note that says thank you Josh sne
for quacky and so they him and Lynn had
named the koala bear quacky and they
would take it on the road with them and
you know have it order a bunch of room
service and they'd be like who ordered
all this food was it quacking that you
know and so it was just a fun little
like if anybody read that in those notes
they have no idea what quaky is but it's
a stuffed koala bear my God that talked
like Mitch Hedberg that I gave to him oh
my God and I'll tell you this this is my
favorite Mitch thing so when I was
recording an album um it was actually
the first thing I ever recorded pre-
Comedy Central it was literally just a
homemade CD to have to sell on the
road um I was opening for Ron White and
uh oh yeah you opened for all blue
collar like the tour right at one time
yeah so I was opening for Ron at a club
um he had already started selling out
theaters but he had had this club date
booked and he wanted to honor it so it
sold out like nine shows in four days I
mean it was like insane we did three
shows on a Sunday oh my that's how many
tickets sold and so I was like well I'm
going to record this week you know from
the feature spot I'll just do a bunch of
different sets cuz I know that it's
going to sound the same in the same club
and that every show is going to be
packed yeah so I recorded all these sets
and the MC rest in peace his name was
Ricky pi and he just passed away not
long ago but he had the thickest
southern accent you have ever heard so I
had all these sets that I was really
happy with but they all started with
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Jo
schne and I was like I cannot have this
dude like introducing me on my CD right
so the next week I was in um I was in
Nashville with Mitch and uh and he was
like he how how' the recording go and I
was like well it was great except for
the intro and I told him what had
happened he goes do you still got your
recording stuff and I was like yeah and
he goes I'll record for you and I was
like really and he's like yeah go get it
so in the Green Room of the nationville
comedy club uh zany um he recorded what
was the intro for my first CD and he
says uh Hey everybody it's Mitch
Hedberg grab a drink sit back relax and
listen to The Comedy of my favorite Josh
sne and so that was the intro that led
into my set and then of course he passed
before
uh my Comedy Central album came out and
I just felt like I couldn't do it again
with like out being able to ask him if
it was still cool you know I think it
would have been but it just felt weird
so it just kind of made that first CD
that much more special but he he
recorded the intro to my first CD and
it's out it's out there um on like
YouTube and stuff and I've I've put the
audio like you know on the anniversary
of like his passing or his birthday or
something sometimes I'll just like write
little stories about him and I always
share the audio for a minute so it's
pretty awesome yeah I didn't even cuz I
he think he died on April Fool's Day the
day before the day oh so I I heard about
it on April Fool's Day and I and I was
like this has got to be a joke this
would be something Mitch would be like
oh he dies on April Fool's Day there's
no way and then you're like oh no it
actually did yeah the last time I saw
him he was doing a Comedy Central tour
with Steven Lynch who's like super funny
um comedian musician and um he I our
paths just happened to cross I was out
with the blue collar guys and uh they
were doing a show in Michigan at the
same time so I stopped by to just kind
of hang out Al Madrigal was the MC who
was like amazing but he was like you
know the MC that at that time not really
anybody had heard of and I like fell in
love with him immediately so funny but
um Mitch asked me to do a guest set this
was like February of 04
I think um and he was like you want to
do some time I was like Mitch this isn't
like a late show Friday at the punchline
like this is like a theater like you
don't do guest sets at theaters he's
like you can do it in my show so I did
like 10 minutes on this theater show
where I was just there to hang out and
um not knowing that would be the last
night that I saw him because you know a
couple months later he passed away but
uh that night I was at um I was doing a
show in Lex inton at the University of
Kentucky and on my way to the gig my
manager called and he said hey have you
heard anything about Mitch and I said no
why and he goes well the rumors going
around that that he passed away and I
was like I haven't heard anything about
that and he goes well the club that he's
supposed to be at this weekend is
calling around trying to find another
comedian and I was like oh man I was
like no I haven't heard anything but
I'll try to find out and and uh a woman
that used to work here at the punchline
um she was real close with Mitch and
Lynn Kathy and so I messaged her asking
if if she had heard anything when I
didn't hear back and uh I go on stage at
at the school and when I come off stage
I um I look at my cell phone and it was
there was uh 36 Miss calls from like the
word had gotten out and everybody had
called to make sure that I had heard
about about it but it was like as soon
as I saw that I was like well I know
what these are all about yeah so I know
such a such a loss to of a human and as
to the business you know just like just
people won't get to know like how cool
he was and like what he did for
completely unknown people like me to
just like help him out wherever he could
I mean it's just like ridiculous there's
I have so many stories but I hope they
all get told by people someday I know I
had never heard that side of them like
I'd only heard just story I think I
heard Greg Warren tell a story of like a
funny story of them like a hotel and him
trying to play P cash like I've heard
that side of it of him and like how like
how he was off stage was like similar to
on stage he was kind of out there but I
haven't heard that side of him like like
just how generous he actually was you
know I I know someone's working on a
documentary
and I know it'll it'll get done and
it'll be like people will be just amazed
by his story but I think they'll be even
more amazed by just how many people like
me have stories about just like cool
stuff that he did that he did not have
to do and knowing especially at that
time you know cuz social media wasn't a
thing you know so it wasn't it wasn't
ever these stories would get around so
much quicker now you know but um they
just came from like a genuine good dude
that love the business and love to see
you know help out young kics and was he
like the guy like in the industry was he
like at the top of the food chain at one
point is that how big he got I mean I
think he was headed that way yeah you
know he did a tour before the Steven
Lynch tour he did a tour for Comedy
Central it was him DAV tell and Lewis
Black they were all on the same show
together and uh he was starting to just
like literally just starting to do
theaters and I just think that I mean if
it was today he would be the number one
comedian in the universe I mean he would
sell out everywhere he went just because
the exposure that catapults people to
that type of Fame he he was built for
that he had the look he had the jokes
he like I just remember I'm just being
in awe like in the back of the room no
matter where we were every time just I
cannot wrap my head around the fact that
someone would know a joke by heart and
still want to hear him say it yeah like
it it happens to me once a month maybe
from somebody who has memorized
something from dry bar like will you do
the whatever bit and then like it this
was every night where he would do an
hour of brand new stuff and then he
would do a half hour of people just
yelling out stuff they wanted to hear
and they're just it's not like B Machine
story that's 13 20 minutes or whatever
but it's literally just like a oneliner
people like just say that set up
punchline yes that's so cool I know wow
I know it's I appreciate you sharing
that I haven't heard anyone talk about
that side of them before it's very cool
yeah like I said a lot of a lot of
people got to see it you know yeah um
and it's just it's just unfortunate for
so many reasons but primarily like just
a like just a loss of like this unicorn
comedian
human it's it's uh it stinks yeah yeah
wow well thank you so much for sharing
that man I'll talk about those I mean
like I said I was Geraldo atel Patrice
you know uh I mean itel is still alive
but I just was so lucky to be such an
impression
Age and and years in the business to be
able to like like literally learn from
the best Bill bur Gaff again for bigly
uh what all these people coming through
that club oh yeah that you got to just
oh yeah oh
my oh yeah it's wild it's wild and it's
wild to like hear your reaction to that
because I
remember being the young guy and when
people would say oh yeah I worked with
Bill Hicks or oh yeah s s kenon used to
come like they would say these names be
like
what they worken the com
like you know and then now I'll just
tell like a mid story like yeah it was
awesome and then like other you know
younger guys would be like you met him
like what they're people wait a minute
they're comedians the do clubs yeah it